Hello my name is Brian Gerber and I'm going to have a conversation with Adrian Spratt.
for Visible Lines in Oral History Project at the New York Public Library.
It is July 1, 2015.
and this is being recorded at 135 Willow Street in Brooklyn Heights.
Adrian, I know, I known that you lost
that you lost your vision at age thirteen.
But since you have become an attorney and have attended Amherst and
Harvard. Why don't we start though with your early life. Why don't you tell me
a little bit about where you come from and growing up there.
I did it. OK I've missed. I was born in  and the time of Darlington which in
is in the northeast of England. In 1954
and uh I was born, my mother used to put it um
my legs angled at the knees so it was as if my feet were praying
and I had a cleft palate, um
So the cleft palate was repaired before I remember by surgery. And they did a pretty good job.
pretty good job and
job and. I spent five months, uh,
months. In the hospital when I was seven. Having my
Achilles tendons transplanted and other sorts of surgery.
surgery. Without that I would not have been able to walk.
So when I was four. I was also diagnosed with myopia.
Which the technical meaning of myopia is that the sockets of the eyes
large for the retina and so the retina is stretched.
As far as I know I was never able to see out of my left eye and-- Although I don't know
what measure my vision was in the right eye--
um-- while I could see quite well I had to go
to the school for the partially sighted
--which-- they don't exist any more in England but they did at the time. Now by then we have moved down
to Middlesex a suburb of London and I went to school in London from the age of four
four to ten. The uh cause of my
my various problems is something called Stickler syndrome which apparently is
the most common genetic syndrome there is. I've certainly read that.
Ah, but most people show very few symptoms
and otherwise
Otherwise-- The symptoms are kind of erratic. Some people have vision problems.
Some people
have the kinds of problems I had with my legs--um--
The cleft palate is a symptom of it also.
It's um considered a-a disease of the connective---
a degenerative disease of the connective tissue
Anyway we'll come back to all of that but that was ultimately what
was the cause of my-uh-myopia
So I went to school for
the partner sighted as I said when we were in London
And this meant for me to rise or two and a  half hours in
the morning to school and two and a  half hours back at night. So five hours on
this annoying bus for 6 years.
a. I formed a very close friendship there with Bruce who's still
a friend of mine all these years later. Then we moved north to the town of  Sheffield
my father
was an accountant. In fact, my father has a great story of his own, he left school at
He left school at 14 because his parents couldn't afford books.
This is in what would have been 1942, during World War II.
One way or the other, by going to night school and working in an accounting firm during the day, um
He was able to get uh qualified
qualified um- as what here we would call a C.P.A., over there a chartered accountant um-
A subdivision of Union Carbide. The American chemical company
that no longer exists. They hired him.
They brought him down to London. Then they sent him up to Sheffield to be
a managing accountant. We lived there for three years and then he was asked to come to New York office
Which is how our family ended up in here in the States.
It happened at the same time, just as
I guess my parents decided to move here in the spring of sixty seven
and--uh they informed my brother and me after school was over.
They didn't want to upset us. But my brother was very excited about it, I was a bit uh- I had mixed
I had mixed feelings about it. I didn't really want to leave.
And so we were scheduled to come to New York in November.
And then in September um- I
I experienced a detached retina
uh on my- the side in which I did have vision
And [clears throat] that led to my
my being hospitalized for four yea- four months.
My brother my father came over to the states in November. My mother stayed with me
I was transferred to a London hospital
hospital. Finally was allowed to leave
leave and come to the States in January. I still had some vision. So
for my first  two months or so in the States. I had some vision. I was able
to see things like the
the ice on a beach in uh Darien, Connecticut where we ultimately moved
um- and vividly remember
the house where we're staying with friends of my father's in New Jersey.
And the absence of fences, um, all these trees.
I remember a glass of orange juice in the morning which somehow is a very vivid image for me
for me um- but I had
But I had surgery again on the retina at Columbia Presbyterian in March
and I'm afraid--Whatever vision I had before the operation
that operation put an end to [chuckle] so I had
So I had a very tiny aperture of vision where I could basically see color
for the next few years and that closed towards the end of high school
Okay, tell me about when you were in England
England and you-you- well two
Well, two questions, I have really. One is
Was the detached retina also connected with the Stickler's? --Yes it was--
Yes it was-- I should have explained that, yes--  it was, it was, OK and what was
was it like-- in other words, forgive me Brian, the way in which it was connected was
The Stickler's causes myopia
So the retina was stressed. So I was always susceptible to having a torn retina and in fact.
So throughout my childhood I was told I had to avoid knocks, I had to avoid being hit on the head,
had to avoid any sort of violent motion and actually what triggered it
was I got hit by a cricket ball when I wad playing in school. On the head.
OK so. So they kind of, this Stickler's kind of restricted
what you could do. Yes. You couldn't play a lot of games
That's right yes-- wild things-- When I was in cub Scouts.
I could do, you know, the knots and things like that but I couldn't play any of the-the games, you know, the football um anything
Anything that involved rough and tumble
And You went to the school for the partially sighted
partially sighted. --Yes-- all the time you were in England? That's a really good question.
By pure chance when we moved to Sheffield.
I did start out at a school for the partially sighted but they decided to experiment with
that school, the first in the nation,
and moved us
to what in England is called a comprehensive school.
Long explanation but it's basically what we would call a public school here.
And I went to that school for two years
for two years plus three weeks in September before my retina detached
So I was actually one of the first students  to be integrated, to use the term
of
And I never wanted to go back to a special school after that.
And what um well what was the
What was the difference actually between the public school and the special school, as far your studying and learning
you studying or um, you know, learning. Did they have different- --You know Brian--
You know Brian this is a great question. It's a long long answer but let me see if I can do a shorthand version.
The school in London--Essentially
Each of, each year you had almost the same teacher for every class
So I had my last year I had Miss Eades for
my English class. My arithmetic. History.
All those subjects and... I kind of wish I hadn't mentioned her name
because she was a very bad teacher. So if you got stuck with a bad teacher you're really in bad luck. My very first teacher
teacher at that school was actually very good. And then when I moved to Sheffield-- same thing
we had one teacher for all of our courses. So I had, I have to say, a bad teacher when I first arrived
first arrived but then for my
but then for my next three months I had a very, very good teacher who took me under his wing and at
that point there's
there's an examination that they used to give in England. I don't think they do anymore. It determines
what quality of school you go to. If you pass, you go to, obviously,
a higher academic school. If you fail, you don't.
and this teacher
We would spend, you know, play time
going through all the kinds of questions and subjects and things that I would have to
learn to pass this exam. And I did pass it.
It made no difference in the end because I had- I ended up going to this com- this uh- comprehensive school. Which was more mixed
more mixed
But in that sense
I guess going to school for the partially you were lucky if you got a great teacher often
you often got not such a good teacher. Whereas in the regular school the comprehensive, or public, school
a public school, I had
I had a different teacher for every subject.
Sometimes different students in different subjects.
So you got a lot more variety and, you know, presumably you've got people who are
more knowledgeable in their field. That's one big difference. I think another difference
is when you're in a special school. You feel in some sense
Segregated from the rest of the population. And I know segregated is a lo-loaded word.
Loaded word as I'm saying it, um- whereas
Whereas if you're in a regular school
There are disadvantages, you know, for example I couldn't do Phys. Ed. because it involved too much activity
For my head
But I did have conversations with people I
became slowly, very slowly, but over time I became friendly with people. And I became-- I came to feel
to feel a part of the class
And in a sense, part of a society again. Well not again; for the first time.
So it was very special to me. --Yeah so you--
So you actually felt-- Did you feel more comfortable in the regular school than at the vision school?
Not at first--not at first-- it was very difficult --Yeah-- You know, I had to sit at the front so I could see the blackboard.
Nobody sat-, you know, we had two person desks, nobody sat next to me for the first several months
So I felt very conspicuous.
But by the end of my second year
I--It's not so much that I felt more comfortable--
It's that I felt more stimulated. --Ok. ok. So--
So um, so
So ok so now you're thirteen --Yes-- and your family has moved to the United States --Yes--
United States. I guess you didn't go to school immediately because of the vision problem
Let's see we can January, had the operation in March. I
I started eighth grade, which is
Which is a year I was the right age for
For the last five weeks of that school in
Connecticut. Um and they
they told me that the idea was that I would um- get to meet
my teachers because then I would do eighth grade the next year since I'd missed practically the whole year.
I was determined I wasn't going to do that.
And I was really fortunate my parents were extremely supportive
At that point I had no skills
a blind person would need I didn't have Braille, I didn't have typing skills.
So
I-I guess I'm- any books that had been recorded I was able to read
I had to have my parents read a lot to me I had students at the school who'd volunteer to read
I had to dictate all my essays, all my tests, everything. One way or the other
other was all that support I got.
I was able to convince them that I could move on to ninth grade
This is after just five weeks-  --Yeah, yeah--
Yeah. One reason was obviously the school system in England
England was probably about a year ahead anyway.
So some of the material is already familiar to me
me. Um but yeah, one way or the other, yeah
Ha- By the way I think you said Stickler's is genetic
--It is-- Is there- were there are other people in your family that
that-- No I'm the first one
--You're the first one-- That may lead to another story later on
but I am the first one --If you want to do it now, it's fine--
Well the story is along these
these lines. In 198-
198-
1983 i guess, my brother
My brother's wife became pregnant
pregnant and I guess I should make it-
I've used the word "Stickler's" if that was- I've always known that
it wasn't known by that name
name and just at least a decade maybe a couple decades later
later and when I looked into this
It didn't seem to have been discovered by 1954 four when I was born. And yet my parents
parents were told I had a genetic
syndrome I didn't know anything about it, I didn't- It wasn't really a part of my conscious
consciousness. But when my brother's wife became pregnant in
They had their wherewithal to go and get genetic testing for my brother
He was cleared. But they asked me this was [?]
New Haven. I was in New York at the time
time they have got here in New Haven. And they asked me if I
would submit to the test also
So I went there with my girlfriend at the time
Um, I had the chest and that's when they determined I had
had Stickler's syndrome
which meant that I
I was- essentially any child of mine would be- have a 50%
a fifty percent chance of carrying it which is a chance I wasn't willing to pass along
so at that point I became resolved that I wasn't going to have
children um and cause my brother and his wife
went forward with their son who turned out to be a great kid, thirty years
old now. So let me know they've worked out I
think. I was fortunate in the Says I didn't have a driving desire to be a father.
So that since it worked
out. And your family.
When you know when it became clear if you replace the pantry
or.
I'm tending to do right because if I hadn't you know what I haven't really thought of it knows
Charles. We went through a very long process the form of US spent in the hospital
in Sheffield in The London.
I think made a huge difference to me personally and getting it isn't directly I
guess. I have already mentioned
have courses I have to be. While I was a boy. Before I was thirteen.
I just because you're with that against that was one reason why I was up playing on the field and why I
got exposed to being hit by that because a
ball. I just felt that I
was sort of a be Pen be worse and
I was getting impatient with it and not enough of a half. Be myself about
all
that. So when I went to the hospital I was determined first of all. I was
going to handle it well.
The second thing is I was put into a ward with many patients now in England it's very different from
the situation here. Here you might get a private room if you've got the money or to get a
semi private room there. Generally end up in a public wallet in
Sheffield is a world of. Eight
people without transfer to London it was water twenty two people thought it was
a big room.
But this. There isn't a spree to call them both wards of
the guys who are play friendly. Most people are not likely
to lose a vision they have being high. Issues.
But in each case. I met a guy who was blind in Sheffield.
And that a man who had lost his sight. At the University of Sheffield gator
chemical accident.
Who was as well adjusted as anybody I've ever known was a wonderful one want to
bring in the being here twenty eight at the time.
And then he befriended me and pad. He admitted later
on the surgeon asked
him to be fed me. But to go to sleep and I that helped me a lot. And then
when I was in Sheffield. And so in
London. I was introduced to a patient who is having a much harder time adjusting to
his vision love. They were still he thought it was still
hoping his. He was a Polish.
Credibly bright guy big with thirty mins the most intelligent man that ever known and then he lost
his sight in a radiation abstinent.
And he befriended me to he couldn't believe his that he was had to lie flat. As I had had to
do for two
months. But when I was allowed to get up and walk.
I would love to see him. All the time. And he would make me tell mother loved. And he talked
about his experiences so
on so my. Just went through loss of
vision was
helped enormously by the people I met in the hospital those two I mentioned
and others. And the nursing staff and the
doctors. I think that may have helped my parents too.
Since my patches supported
throughout and your brother who's younger.
Two years ago. To
you about.
But we were not close mean factory really dislike each other what is it my brother said.
As an adult. Since we have to control it
so if he doesn't
understand how it. How he could have
said sort of what I want all this was going on in sort of ignored it. And you know a lot
of side I think. I thought of the I think.
Whenever know the truth of this. I think my brother. Suffered from was attention that
I got. I think he got less attention than he had to plan it
away and. I have to assume that I've taken in the.
The the way we just for like crazy.
Until well into our late teens.
Probably natural reaction. It
is. You know when you say.
OK makes it makes the whole situation as you get older that even though I
said that's true. Yes.
So. So now you're in the United States. Yes.
You become blind. You talked a little bit
about how the five
weeks is where you prove to them.
You should be banned. To keeping track of this
plan and. You want to talk more of go down your adjustment
to blindness and going through the school.
Yes. Some After those five
weeks. You know I think. I want to say I have to mention
is when I came to the States. John you're sixty
seven. Johnny sixty eight.
In March of that year. President Johnson reside on another note he would run
again in June of that other cable. Assassinated.
So you know commit his country that time. And I think that anybody living
here
was a child
of. I kind of the when I want. But it was
a Senate it's just in time to write. Term or is a good word for it.
So resign as a back and I you know
I was I was you know obvious. I was told I had to
go to school for the Blind in Hartford Connecticut pull or kill for six weeks.
In order to get some intense spell instruction.
Had to learn to type. And by tapping me on the
typewriter. So that with those six
weeks to probably of a help for Sally I know the typing help me a
lot without it with someone else. Schools.
OK this is a residential stress take it still
exists. It has year round
student. But by that Point Loma was
blind students are being integrated I think the word he was mainstreamed
into
the various public schools.
So I think most of the kids to read your rounded OK All were either they
have multiple had
accounts. Or they had home situations image of a difficult for them. That was my impression.
So many of us are meant to summer school. Already in public schools
and we can with there for some sort of special training of one kind or another. Most of
the people in fact I have guessing. I was learning it hadn't been there as a regular student at any time in
my life.
And I said I was so nice learned to type was crucial to me
because. Well let me move on because I can hit show how
I became
crucial to make up to. My junior high school with Jennifer Hudson and then
with seven states and grace. So this is the last. You know how
I had to go through the same
equal. Dictating everything. Having a lot of reading done for me.
At one point. I hope. There's
a teacher called not tenured teacher which many black people
be familiar with this is a in the stuff
of a teacher who goes from school system to school
system within seconds of change in this case. Fairfield Connecticut.
This situation has had two brothers all my friends Chris's my
man. And she made me realize my answers which you would
then transcribe it to print. Or sometimes she came I dictate which of a I guess you had time
for. But it meant you know the school day was extended by these two hours
and it was grueling. But one person said to
me. You know. It isn't you know you're taking advantage of people.
Which is not something I want to hear it all. But
I took it to heart and at that point instead of dictating I started typing. I was
convinced a divide type papers.
I would mention what I typed. Things were you know the the. The be a problem with a river
not have a whole page and nothing will come out.
All of the things that happen. But in fact I got pretty adept at it as as everybody does.
When you have to.
And I was talking my own papers and which I will play rather I think it's at some point
in ninth grade.
If I don't know it was. But I made a big difference because then all of a
sudden. I didn't have to be somebody all the time I could work in my
own. When I had tapes like to read my own.
So that helped a lot
to me just interrupt was difficult even if you were in a close.
Yes. Did you did you. Could you recorded. Or did you did you take.
Three just
after the fifth. Two questions that could I have to go to this. I don't remember.
I don't think. Cassette recorders were very book at that point they became available.
You know I don't know that when a punitive or of course they use them once they
did so in order for me to record it Carter would have had to love this is huge.
Sony reel to reel in with the net result is no I did not. I did not take my
classes. And frankly I would have wanted to listen to them again.
I think it has a lot of members ation. I just listened I took in what I could.
I don't mean the people taking notes from a class or buying notes as possible but I don't think so.
So I think I'm in a related memory.
OK All right so you saw anywhere you're in school. Your new stuff. Yes.
You want to talk a little more about the school.
OK because you learn Brown's. And you don't.
So let me be cannot talk about those poll
numbers. Just one of the things I
learned is that the. What sometimes taught the black community is
extremely politicized and polarized. The bill is one of the subjects
really really gets people going.
I am not a fast reader. I find it almost torture. Because of so slow that.
It was necessary for me is indispensable is how I got to high school
college law school and also my job now is if people don't have Bill. They
also perform well in each of those phases. The for me was helpful.
But as I understand
that if you start learning to build a very young age.
Positive brain that most of us
use to read by
sight. Becomes a touch them to reading by touch
through
Braille the brains. This is
a someplace that varied. Seven years old I think I've been eleven years
old relatively early age.
The plane is not. If I pick up fluency in Braille if
you have learned in the very early age.
So there's a you know it has a lot of value. But it. If you
are one of the bags of losing aside early very early life. Is that you can read. Really
fast and. I must say when I've been a good girl readers is quite something I
just clicked pages clipped at that I don't know how to do it.
What did you do have your crew got to
be. I spent some time during homework there was very
limited but
I I know what kind of articles for the school
newspaper. And I was in the
chancellor and I tell you a story about that.
There were seven of us and it just up.
I was an average player not a particularly good
one it was an extremely good player and it
just became a point at the end of.
I guess junior.
Maybe the beginning and I think I may be to begin to see me.
When we had to elect a president of the chest. So the seven of a sudden around this
table. And I figured I was going to vote for this
guy. And then everybody would have the drive as it is of their number one he was
very good of playing chess Number two he had organized told him it's. It is he deserved it.
So he.
Said he liked to run he like to be
president and one of the guys
who wanted to give us a speech and one of me. You know maybe we have some just what I'd like to nominate
somebody else and so we just don't know it said I nominate a jury
and so all of a sudden there's a
competition and. So the guy
who deserve it just means you know the idea. A little bit offended but he had the wherewithal
to get past a great quickness and so. OK John I guess you have to give speeches if you want me
to go further shaken if I said well there's a bit new to me so what do you go first now think about what I'm going to say.
So he went first to get a perfectly purpose speech which along the line. I hate
giving speeches. But I've you know I've I've organized as I've done that.
I think I've got and
you. Mean but I was thinking. As
a tremendous amount of hostility Melor the chance to play this for some reason they didn't like this guy half of them.
I said. If I'm elected president.
I promise to bring. Peace and quiet. And I will be
more than happy is this other guy's resources if it's willing to continue to
provide them.
So we have a reason voted for the guy sitting in
south. Season voted for me.
Respect me really deciding
the. And I was thinking my college applications and how I can have a whole lot of
heads of political activities. And I thought of
unless you prove. I was a question if
you provide a crime.
I think so and I felt like a fraud.
You felt like a fraud Yeah Frogger you voted for us because of that going to let the I knew
the other guys love the people of Israel. So we did.
OK So how did you decide to you really kind of made it through high school.
Yes. Obviously very well. Yes you said you went to her sister.
How did you decide where to go to.
Like I was cancer was tremendously helpful we have that she had
no no knowledge of the American system.
The universes we had of a year and half of it like everybody else
what my parents had not met my father that's going to
fourteen my mother left school when she was sixteen.
So I think a cousin of my father. Going
to Oxford but that was
it the. We really had no experience of
a. You know beyond high school. My high school
counselor guidance counselor. Gave me a list of colleges that he thought I
should consider playing
to. Most of them were small liberal arts
institutions to them with an
analyst and. I pretty much stuff is on those two for
writing reasons well. Yeah because I've heard of it.
And then they went to visit and most I was so taken with the whole community
atmosphere it's in a semi pro. Part of western
Massachusetts town.
And so I thought oh yeah except I mean within a month of my playing.
So by twelve but I knew I was
also. I'm a nurse. Many of you me that this would
never happen today.
The. You do you have a mission. I think I can say. Name team also
don't keep referring to me some anonymous
way. Dean was saying we've
had one experience of a blind student before. And it didn't work out very
well. He had a lot of difficulty getting his reading done.
He ended up relying very heavily on the faculty wise. And in particular
on the president's
wife. So we had some misgivings about that.
He said in a way that made me feel he wanted to accept
me. And that blindness was just a call now that could not be
Saturday. And I wasn't told about this.
I Ching.
So in retrospect. I find it refreshing. But I knew what I was up against.
There's no beating around the bush there's no coding it was no
code words to say what they really meant. It
was in the open. I told him
that. By that point
my diary on the child was in school had a terrible organization.
There was a national organization they were told is for the Blind which you by one of you for
I know that.
And I was accustomed to working with students some of whom would
get would be paid by the state of Connecticut. And they might spend some who of whom
with volunteer.
One radio that I was able to persuade him that I had the resources and he sat on that until March. So
you
know what I'm a left before the people are notified I was there.
Septimus
well. And I went up
challenged in April. For those dozen between I must and.
I loved. And this is a place.
Yeah one has a commuter prestige. That I'd grown up with an
England. Happened. Just by pure chance on the day that is when
my track mentioned I went up here and was
together. There was a meeting in the quad with all of
the college.
Including professors administrators.
And the question
was whether this. How was the school going to protest.
The latest events in
Vietnam and China what they want to play think at that point it was
the bombing of high for the mining if I find a bug up. All I know
it I think that's what the
event. And the discussion which is
so
civil. I was accustomed to discussions in class where people get sort of
aggregating religion other and get kind
of agitated and and a loyal one with are
they you can then. I think they were interesting they're fascinating but they didn't feel
like
rational discourse and I guess that appealed to me a lot. And then everybody spoke so.
Flirting with such consideration for the listeners.
I just went home and wrote life. I said yes I'm allowed to come.
That same evening. It's a nice way
to shoot. It was that it was the right decision. Now.
Hers is ruled. Yes several at this point
to get to the right.
How did you get around. Did
you get of or use a cane I've never heard
of that.
I got on the weekend.
I really don't have a lot of
them on the systems at the time.
I have if it was one of those people who was embarrassed
by the way
Kane. It felt like
a how did I say. I suppose
a. It with a let the scarlet A net has
to print. Started as it.
I mean it had a falling cancer any time
I didn't have to use it I followed it up. So I mean I was on a boat walking with
other people. But I gradually gradually. You know I realize this is just nonsense a guy.
It was not acceptable.
I ventured got the point was walking along with that weapon
myself. This is.
I think a child for a little bit
because. It's funny you
know what look at this but you know I have really tried to make it my life out of writing the
last fifteen
years. And I've been a memoir. Covering my first
up to the public discussion. And of it and what about those sort of never going to write about
tonnages consumers look complex and difficult.
If you go for two
years I've decided that. Everything I've done up to that point in my
life including analyst. Have been pretty much feel good.
It
doesn't I don't mean to say that I can have a choice. As I said he did have choices I had
a choice pencils about which close to Goes Boating. I was entirely by my posting the pressure may well
my the
other. But. And obviously I've worked hard to get the grades
I got. But it all started as there was a pail and I hadn't gone. I
hadn't stray from it one
bit a couple things happened I decided I
wanted to teach English at the college level. My major was
English. And I was advised.
I had some French I'm not because they're too French but I you know Cumberland French forces.
I
decided if I press gotta gotta gotta stop one of
my people fast is actually professional Russian So you know I know you like
Russian literature but you really should learn German that would help you know more such as
OK I'm going to go to summer school to learn German. Now where I want to go to summer
school plays in this puzzle for some reason I'd always been jointer
was not
real which I never been to. So I applied chemical university for the
summer program. And they let me
and to take this jet engine introductory German intensive
course. So.
That trip I took to Montreal.
What kind of attorney pop me
because I was doing something that I no one had expected me
to do as Don't you know following things by myself where I I knew nobody.
So there's and yet making this I actually register a
friend of mine in Maine. So I took a bus to Boston he pick me up.
We spent time at his place in
Maine for week. And then I got on a bus important for this eleven
out journey to Montreal.
And I got my freshman Dean who was picked
as Imus was raped and sort of he
had a lynching. Teachers
and teachers applied to meet me at the bus station and putting up
overnight. And then I would just go to university and just figure things out from
the. When we got to
the border. When the past got to the border of
Canada. Customs. So maybe my
girls
work. And asked me to get out of the bus.
So. And then to ask and they indicated what is Alex Alex
because it's an introduction to German. How do you how do you know how do you read
it and open up a book I said well listen I don't know German have studied it you have read
you a lot and they are probably butcher this so I read him a line.
And he said You must be take this. And he took the but he took the
book. And I was definitely. Mostly by myself.
And I figured the bus to God My love is on the bus.
What are they going to do. Just as at that point in my life I just knew that
that or rather I guess I decided
that whatever happened. I was to go with her.
Anyway. They came back and said OK.
Show me back to the bus and it's the same bus that kept his eyes in that hole
out. If there was a was
six eight in the imbalance when I walked down the aisle back to my seat. The woman who had been sitting
next to me I think we can control what each other but she moved to the window.
I sat down and said nobody said a word.
We make another how into Montreal you lived up to all of the
past figures in the next this woman would be. She
was. With the. Die
I was to learn to just have no two days earlier.
And. They took me to that place. And made a nice meal
and then. Wonderful. And then they drug me to the universe the next day.
And then from there on edges. Oh I'd
rather the next day I got an orientation. As stated in orientation session
with somebody
with the Quebec. I don't know what they call themselves now the the. There's been any but
the department for vision impaired people for the blind whatever. He came
in an alum there so we went from light on which is up on approach remote
while. All the way down to shut up street and then a long ship of
street to. The place was going to be taking this German
calls. And so that took and I was alone walking in even after
was accused about forty minute walk. Even when I was accustomed
to so let him with over. He said. OK.
I said well can we do some more like. I never use a Metro my own how do I do
that
subway. Well you know I want to turn structures for the
whole problems of Tibet. Now. What's real what is a very big city.
And a poem is looked at back to St Giles the size of Texas in the area. So I
feel pretty selfish enough but I said. Well. Anyway so he Greece give me one more lesson
in their week later
and show me how tos ee a matter of my own. Which I didn't did and so
I that whole summer was dipping around lunch real. There's places.
On my own and with friends and was a fabulous time
and you learn to be myself. Forgive me. You learn to be more
self-reliant Exactly.
Is another conceive of the rebels driving it reflects a
psychological step and it's more the more psychological step in anything else.
Yes. Did you graduate from Amherst with the Major. Yes I
guess I got it a similar day and I was elected the commencement speaker.
To remember to pick one.
No I do I I think it is. Again you know you have to question the way that I can formulated
I think is a somewhat rambling
essay. That was sort of trying to make a point
that we go on all about worse and worse and worse. And in the end.
The silence or something like that.
OK so. To you but you said you went to law school you went to
a lot
harder to do is at a measly after graduating
from law. Yes. And so I was there to start because I mentioned to you that I
had wanted to be. I was a teaching years on the color. College level.
I was always between my sophomore junior Yes.
I decided OK. Now I need a job.
I wish I went and asked for a
job and had never been to the south before I want to go to the south and.
You know for me. Just go to some place. Traveling through.
It's not Nova satisfy. What a ghastly lives a place.
One way or the other able to get a job with a community action
agency and a child of yeah can build in the northeast corner northeast
North
Carolina. What I was that's what is very difficult to get rid of.
Can I I was seventy five dollars bike Weekly. My
rent was small enough that it actually meant something in that image so much
as ever to
fly to Washington D.C. for the July fourth weekend. To see friends of mine and like
that all on the salary.
But I discovered I just I couldn't pay for readers so you know I had to
realize what it
is yet occasion never was not high among the people who were
able to volunteer. Is a real part
of. But I really I mind the work the agency did they
did start. They implement programs job training.
Funny people jobs over ideas. So as soon as a little program.
I realize I really want to contribute in some way. At that
point. And the question was
how. I don't so.
It's become it becomes clear to me
that there's a real risk and going to teaching. Thinking. Going
into teaching. That's what I have to have about seven years
of of graduate school and I wanted to be financially independent sinners
and. And second of all
just. Q Many people work in the same job that I
did more than I felt competent somehow but on the other hand I
get so anyway so that was one. Well opportunity one option I was
considering that. Then I thought OK
so a lot of this work with social work in North Carolina. How
about becoming a social worker.
I came to paging and I probably would have money to be able
to hire my readers. Again I find myself and. Bishop depending
on something that wasn't entirely reliable.
I thought about psychology. Had some reservations about
the moment that Iraq law as people
do and. So let's read this article.
OK so. And did you
find. Was school getting. You know the problems of
being blind to the
different. She
was. Well.
I don't think the problems are being blind were different I think.
When one. One
respect. The first one to say
that I was your last project through your program and my three years the.
There were six other places
that it was complete contrast to what I've gone through before
and what high school I was a second by student. Same thing that I
must tell you should have. First or second person in
whatever institution I ended up
in. However is different. There was a
woman who was a graduate student who was teaching at the fetch a spirit of
diplomacy. And then there are other. Blind of the blind
or students and with various interests.
So at that point you know I wasn't an exception. In that
school. I don't wonder. The real problems for
the people who don't have any vision and is up and I didn't.
Is
insomnia. And if it has a name the seven twenty four.
Since I was something like that. And so I.
For most of my life know I being infected by some in the way I was having that up in north
or was
that exam period was a nightmare for me because
I think you know. Between that syndrome and. Just the sheer
tension taking exams or lot more exams I've taken. College college as much about writing papers.
So I was totally fighting. Just just being get tired. Each other
and so that was a real struggle I mean even though it's not blindness as such
is so near an outgrowth of
blindness. And then my second year.
I got
mononucleosis. So that was another thing I had to settle this.
So I can go still harder. But I was a partner particles of insomnia.
And partly because it wasn't a subject that came naturally to me
as others have as such I said. I remember
there's a woman in my my hospital class who like to read poems.
And she she looked at her I suggest you look at my right hand surgeon general.
Your logic line is a very long.
And then she looked at my left hand over the last was read on here that means you're going to learn it.
So there was so.
So yes. One million I got through
those and you know I got my summer jobs I got a job in Wisconsin because
I want to go to the upper Midwest. Working for the state public defender.
My numbers between first and second year. For my second year I interviewed a very special firms.
I think it any of
us. There was a period lies through that at
Harvard who had done an experiment just to make the public.
But she sent. That's a trainee application to very
slow in New York and Boston.
In half of them she indicated she was
blind and the other half she did not.
She got invited to interviews by all of those rare she did not indicate it. Ten to none of that
Reggie
did. So it's pretty clear we
had a problem. Yeah yeah.
But one of the people I interviewed one of the organizations was a minister the attorney general's office.
David
Gray and between not getting the experience or you know
the private firm experience I was hoping to
get at between just how much I like these guys. I
was really happy to go there. Simple Minnesota. So I did
that and I had to graduate.
Now. This is pretty much anyone thirty of them
still in both cases they are they also well.
There is doesn't count headed out of his you know I got along great
a misstating touch for a long time afterwards. You certainly would have me back. And the Minnesota
people have me a
job. And I thought they were funny tell me by that point it's clear to me I was astonished.
And I also wanted to commit the
crimes which is what I tell him it's constant.
So my last year and most of us in terms of employment
I
was looking into
various criminal defense
organizations have to do with. Legal
research. Mainly with
readers with me.
It should still be obvious. Except in mind that we have a certain body. And there were no computers.
So I was really depended on
readers. And it's not
just indicated that it's not just a question of having them read text.
I would have to. I would have
to tell them what I needed from cases. What positive step.
Something called Shepherd izing. Which means you want your very case you think is relevant to the point you want
to argue. You see where the case has been cited that's a fairly complex system.
So I had to educate my research is
that. And there are various other research tool so every time I took on a
new reader. I have to go through this. Educational process as well. Teaching
process. But I was because you have
to reset the really. The Go.
No The only time I've worked with. I generally avoid work with us today or.
No students because I wanted to be sure that it was my own work product.
No local people have
that. That's a part of your accent and picked.
But it's not just an ethical issue. But I want to be sure that it was my We're part of the it is the exception to
that was when I was working on a joint project for example for the.
The truck that was called the moot court competition. We risk.
We had to part of the US. So I did work with a friend who's a law student. And I was actually very
experienced this from working with
her. There were no books.
I actually know the because books were recorded by recordings for the blind again.
They
were more lost more than any other two. Totals for the climbers
was invaluable for me. And even books that hadn't been recorded. If I
was able to place a
request. Had enough. They had a early enough in the
summer. The tech to start arriving as a semester read on.
So you want to go into criminal to. Yes. OK And did you. Yes you did for
a job. Yes.
Yes. And specifically on the appeals level.
At that point I was really hooked on need to research I was hooked on more than anything making legal arguments
and putting them in writing.
There are very few opportunities available and even a few of them that the paid in any way.
I would call
adequate. The job. I got the jobs
are interesting me. I'm retired forward here in New York City. With the Legal Aid
Society. I had come to New
York. You know Mike my family that can die
in Connecticut. I had a number of friends from college and law school who live in the New York
area so we would come to intern New York to me expand the day whatever.
So that was my experience in New
York and next month so I didn't want to move there and first it was really.
I have to say I love Boston and. It's not a very friendly place just not it. You know what I was in
the Midwest in the south accompanied her family people the bottom of all the cold.
But I had so many college friends and also feds. That I became
very and I just became very touched the city. I don't know the press being reserved I grew up in England.
But you know it to me was just just I just
had their stupidity it didn't appear to mean any other way but I have a job.
So I
moved to New York.
I busted. You know to people this new you know. By know each other a little bit we. You have a.
Your former colleague of my partner. Lower than we just had lunch before we did
was taping sessions I would explain to you. Is it the drug or finding my apartment here.
But we could go on forever with this one with the other a first
apartment here in Brooklyn
Heights. And I
had one or two friends you moved here from law school.
But nobody living in this neighborhood. I really had to figure out a lot myself trying
to achieve was one
story. Believe myside he was down in the
park growing in time time and hadn't been in a city hall is on the same block there. Jane
are music well used to beyond. People know that
name. So I think of working with
as giving him the blower
option I contacted as a serious a contact at the
lighthouse. Jassem for orientation.
To my
workplace. They said. You live in Brooklyn.
It's not our job. So I can't have the what was then called industrial holes in
the blind. Him but it was not taught as a carer
services. And they said well we don't really know Manhattan.
But will help you
out. So they sign with this woman.
So it has an
instructor and regiment than she had no idea
learn between a trivet we figure things
out and being no intentional structure she knew your
various landmarks to point out to me that would help me and my
journey in much any involved is cheating separate start really to Park Place.
Subway
stop. But others that had to cross over city hall part and then I
had to cross over.
Parkhead protecting them and I think. If you there for the end of six lanes.
Perhaps get to a certain spot. So that cost safely. You know let. Others
have lived worked and another chapter Patton's worked. All of that she was very
helpful with and you know one way or the between the two of us really because the figured
out. But that's what I hear. Also I live up to the point.
Every institution of the blind have been really helpful to me or my professors have been great. And
my teachers in store that will stay. The mystery is this is
where found my first
conflict. In New York yes.
So what. So you started legally. Yes. What
was it like there were your first piece is what was there any reaction from the clients
to
you or my cursor in
general in this is doing the people's work.
They've all been convicted. I think I'm in that one of my tights once
a
teenager who actually liked a
lot.
Had a variety of cases.
While. Involved a guy who had robbed
a supermarket.
Only cold blustery snowing. January day.
He got any time drove off. But the peak. Caught up with him. Soon
enough and they had this chase. All the way down to be curating into Sunset
Park had about thirty miles an hour. Because the weather the SO BAD.
But one was there that they kept going and they caught him and. So I have got
his appeal I don't know what is your what the legal
issue. I had a guy who was
convicted of
murder. A guy going into a bar on
the west side of the west of
this kind of open fire. He
killed three people injured.
Two. One of them was the particularly the. And the
by bartender. You know. John W.. This guy whoever it was
named and shot him point
blank. And they just left. There's no obvious I recall
just. I just I mean I don't know if it took me from the top but I know he left.
The evidence against him
was. Was I mean this is said it was definitely
him. One eye witnesses as it doesn't it wasn't him went through to run
Sure. There's one of the piece of evidence which was it to reflate
or this guy was arrested at the scene of a robbery.
With the same gun. So essentially my argument was
think I'm insulted because she was
unreliable and. Anybody with half a brain with dumps like God. So
chances were. The guy in the second lobby wasn't him.
So if you know.
Now. And they have pissed of
the appellate division which is the court that bothers and
square. Which handles appeals
from state Supreme Court cases. I should say state.
Cases in Manhattan. In the
Bronx. And they do not.
You know. By my
argument.
Did you went to court. So. Argued. Yes.
Yes. That's a question. I've
read I
think you want to in directly
without at Minnesota's in the attorney general's office there. I was busy. So look at
the general's office he had a variety of different cases
great. But I'm. I have some vague memory with this I
must've had some contact with
the. Whatever organization they have a vision impaired people in
Minnesota for time is not going to cause i'm a guy and I was amused by Minnesota cock of
the
guy. He asked me something to do with work.
And I didn't have the answer.
At that point I said. How about a call you
back. And he said you know when you're blind you really have
to be really with answered you have to do you have to know your stuff or somewhere there
is always a speech. In one sense.
Was unfair.
Because why. What was wrong with my calling him back.
But on the other hand. I think he made a really good
point in the abstract which I took to heart. Which
was to the extent
possible. I would have
to be eight be as prepared with
answers. As I could be and. In the same vein.
Going to court. I thought it was very
important that I present myself with as
much autonomy as possible.
The first department. This is his appeals court in
Manhattan. Is very helpful in that regard. Not not
by not intentionally. Been there for a very long
time but because of the five judges justices who were sitting
that day at the front.
You have two that turns one
to the plaintiff's cause
any. The district attorney depending on the kind of case. On one side.
And you have
the lectern for the
defendant on the fence on the other.
On the other left. And then there are several
rows of seats
facing the judges. And there's an hour down the middle.
I would guess the caught early ever go over the read evidence for driving results back over the
river. I mean the subway station
nearby. And we make sure we've got a seat where I could sit on the aisle.
Near the front.
Now a lot of kids the heard in the afternoon on a dipole than likely to be
told as I'm home I can I stand up.
I go down the aisle.
I actually said I've We had to survive before the top is in session. I'm practicing events.
I gota get right to the elected without a problem because I've practiced
it. That I would know what to do I get my talk as wait for the other side to get their
top of their argument. And then I was there to
walk back to the does or what does the code or. My witness stand up she made me where
we live together.
So totally out of it was very important to me. So you know when you ask. When he said
I I was in court. Yes. That's a very important part of pending trial
look. So you. How we're really
going to know how he
asked her what happened was they didn't like me.
You know
I would say with a muscle or with a woman. As
it was in those school. Was a general store she
she she was very much a business which is the only person I knew in college you read Wall Street Journal.
She got into the restaurant
business and. We were very close.
And just so so why can't you know what I think effect what are we having a fat like I have we have a
relationship. You have to have
being in a job for a lot. You know for these two years.
Because you need to know failure
because at some point. When you're when you're in a job think they go about
you and you're going to be very upset and then happen that's when start going
up and Legal Aid is.
You know when I talk about this and when I write about this.
Mr Diaz. Beyond the point now.
I don't want it to be
about me defending my work.
Holiday defending
themselves but there were certain things that I
learned I think the thing that most troubled me when I was there.
I try to explain this in a way that makes sense.
Each of us lawyers. Well there is a status to providers and
the supervisors. What what a supervisor Besides every priest that was in by
the staff
attorneys. So I had my first degree stand by the woman is
supposedly restraining me.
And then. And then essentially was put in the pool today. The next person
who DO with you my work.
So a problem that we still are
drafted and the problem was that I haven't. He did me a while to figure out what this
was when you realized I was on in fact you know I
was completely on the trial transcript when you're doing appeals
work. One part of the transcript was the
prosecutor's summation.
To do it. Now. I haven't used that. And the reason I haven't used
that had to do with my experiences in Wisconsin.
Which is where because they come again I think as a whole I want to skip all that and just say.
I hadn't used it I had a reason why I had used it.
It was a mistake. I should have used it.
But the conclusion that the supervisor Drew
was it should've been just that look you know when
you've got a resource. You're representing a client you use all the resources. Resources a cat.
That's a legitimate point to
make. But if confusion is she drew was
it because I can see I can be relied on to read the whole transcript correctly.
Now. I have certainly the cautions in place. I have
my readers read every page
number. I have a case file a trip to my side
of the desk. I handed over each item mother's emotion. Whether it was
an interim decision whether it's an exhibit whatever. I would hand over the yard to my reader.
Have him or her read it to me.
Hand it back to me I make my notes I put it back in the folder I take the next item handed to them.
So I was in control the whole time what was red and I made sure we were the entire file. All the way from
going to
and several really
unfair. What was really bad about what she did
was. That
she had put in an instruction and any time.
I submitted a brief.
I had to submit a trial transcript with it.
I was only lawyers objected to that
requirement and it was.
Demobilizing. Hand. Yet he
never improve from that point. The matter how much I learned how much I proved
has been a year so I was writing puter top if you. Time as
a few corrections.
But I still getting very negative
reviews. Now the reason. Office work. I
wasn't alone in this. It wasn't just because I was
blind and. I don't I can't say how much that contributed.
There's some of us who are very highly thought of some of the survey police or the girls on
that subject alone
time. But I would just said it's just as my kind of indication. Wrong that
big
issues. These ladies semi private but most of us funding comes from the city.
The city is all over was unhappy with the labor because they were producing enough food.
You know the Ne Ne needed more turns to be represented which is fair enough it's
logical. So the supervisors run under a lot of press. To get
these cases are we a separate units under a lot of pressure to get the cases out.
I was on the elevator one day after I'd already got another job and I didn't like the moment.
I was on the elevator taken a one
day and happened at the president of the canape was on the same elevator usually
different floor.
He was president the whole society which had a whole variety of services.
He said. Congratulations. And I think most of you know to
a body part of the job. But I thought this is giving this to myself. The
congratulations after. What those who walk through is a go because for being the most
productive attorney
office. Anyway I learned that I was never
told anybody else. Can come. Just a casual comment I mean your image is
a great guy is a nice guy.
I learned so many things from that I one thing is that
the. The the very first lecture we've got a legal aid
in this the seven of us who knew
that in September. At the very first lecture that they had an officer.
I like she was place like a private. So the assumption is that all your work
would be perfect.
The only colors are going to get of criticism of a negative.
Otherwise it's assumed that is perfect.
And there's really not very good because there is a come from a variety of those dollars
and I think many of the press gauges we've worked hard. We had the going to
lose. And we were not going to get emotional support and emotional support
really does matter.
Yeah. And I know what it's like
to be in a job where you know well thought of and that's a really rough
way to start your career.
But I was really fortunate. A friend of mine from college I lost
also having been working in the attorney general's office here in New York City.
The state attorney general's office with a kitchen. Force Protection Bureau.
And he introduced me to that office.
And they hired me. And things turned around.
OK So what's going to
do. And how long were you there.
I was at seventeen
years. I
began as a dedicated
meaning not was to skim it was a definite I mean
this is such an elaborate name it should really be consumer protection.
We. If you don't have a serious complaint against
a company or if we knew that they're engaged. Or we could prove rather that are engaged in some kind of
live. Persistent. Illegal conduct.
We were it is a choice that what we were trying to negotiate a settlement almost always. And if need be sue them.
So that was my work for the first four
years. You start. No longer on the appeals level. I
was in the trial
level. I did know that your trial that
if you like I said it was one child comes to mind I did you want.
Most of it was a negotiation of one kind or another or filing papers.
And having kids be so pretty much in the
papers. But. We also had
a mediation unit.
Lot of
lawyers will try to resolve into individual complaints filed with others.
I'm OK closely with those
people. And I found a very warning.
Because the long haul or got with cases where we were suing
people more
so this could have been settled it does need to guard your the celebrity.
You know all these Bollinger papers.
In many ways just kind of glamorous. I got to do T.V. work I'm
like cases I was on T.V. news a few
times. But I just thought that it
could be done more economically could be done with less of the businesses. In some cases I thought we
were rather harsh
sometimes and sometimes it is OK. Obviously that's
true. And one of the other I work closely with a mediation program and it
was noticed at one point I was asked after I'd been there for years if I would be willing
to take over that
unit which I was. And that was a very good time
for me.
Because I was able
to see. It was a
fairly new unit.
We had a whole lot of
history. I was able to meet with the help my mother. In fact.
Let me begin to strain. My first case I held a meeting with all the mediation
stuff and said
No I will not I know I'm in charge and I really don't know what you do.
You're going to have to teach me. Give me six months. And
that's and by then I hope I can
be more of a contributor. The no than the trainee
in
effect around. And they were great. We were very close again of
a amicable way. I was able to appoint a deputy who
is still a friend. But I did of them as
night. And then when he left to go
to at the age of forty five to little still. Figured if I could be
alive so so he then as it were to apply to another guy. As my deputy.
His posts are friend and a really good
guy and so full of essentially thirteen or fourteen
years. We just kept improving and improving that person we handled. Eighteen
thousand complaints a year.
I was eventually asked to take over the whole state why program which
is fifteen or sixteen offices. So we do fifty thousand employees.
Evolve toward a nation with lawyers in various beers really within the
agency. And a lot of the mistreated stuff. I I want
to keep updating. Some areas of teaching the laws
apply federal state and. You know
city. Which is pretty comprehensive there are so many consumer
protection services standing.
I go to a guy sitting mediators hoster resources so they
became a
very streamlined. Program. And because of all of that there are a lot
of disputes that I got involved with my mother and like be involved directly
in trying to resolve a dispute. I'm more likely I
would help a mediator figure out what strategy to
use I reviewed every letter before it went out.
And what's the world if we got a lot of complaints against a company rather than sue them. I would ask them to
come in and see if you can work
out a solution to the to the more generic problem they're
having which usually worked out very
nicely. So it was a very nice was a thing it
was most amazing about it was here was no very politically
sensitive situation. You know the attorney general in your selective upset.
And yet. I got almost
no.
Interference from the powers that be.
Come. I think I had only one discrete whole time I was there about a particular complaint that we are
handling. And we want to pressure sometimes you have a
lot of pressure to handle. To place a canter some legislation that only makes sense.
But the most part. We were able to run. Quite a bit handling and
successfully. So it was a great experience. Years
review. Well as an intelligence office
from John you're aiming
to intercept that night in a.
So this is kind
of consumer affairs really to crawl.
If you use like the movie. For consumer
protection. You kind of middle. It's interesting you raise up
like
the. The most venerated lawyer in
the whole book in that office was a guy needs argument. And he was essentially the round
nadir of New
York. You see he would tell stories along the
lines. Well when I first started this work.
I was going to call in
the judges say what the hell are you doing here what does a tenant. Attorney General got to do with
this private dispute.
And I got a call and it just says.
How did want to talk in so long to get here. As you say has been
a transformation in how consumables. Have come into effect how much
we've taken for granted now.
And he just goes to really an interesting point
to me about organizations when I was in your community actually lives in North Carolina.
There is a relatively new I was I think in the. I don't know five six you know the
most and let God I work for who have been a Peace Corps volunteer
and
Micronesia. And some advice. He
says you know. In this
particular useful life of an organization like this. Ten
years. When I was a ten general's office
as you say but
I needed
to consumer protection was pretty much accepted but it was still
new enough that it is attracted idealistic lawyers and all
that all of
us. But as I
stated. It turns out in the time is named Robert pavement is Bob Abrams
is a really really good guy a guy been a politician's
integrity. Wonderful human being
he decided to run for federal office for the U.S. Senate.
And nine hundred ninety two.
Having been you know still attorney general says nine hundred seventy eight.
His opponent was out a
martyr and a couple of things just just for
the fun of the above and I remember hearing a debatable. Of all things the Don Imus
show between papers and a
mother and. It was awful. Because the mother was I'm not going
to tack
dog. And even says had had no counter-terror just couldn't have had
no way of fighting
back. And he didn't help is on the Don Imus show.
Which is so used to like I really come to
hate that.
The other thing was by that
point. The Office. It was just a villains who were
thinking that all the office itself had begun think has in fact
a reporter's by that's been thinking fragile and that was partly because it's in the Reagan era.
And the Reagan administration was not read the country from a protection of. For example.
Our office is one of the big ones in getting.
Have that instilled into
come. The federal government was a quiet on
that at the time. I found
that the. I guess what you call the bread and butter consumer protection cases were
just not being handled anymore. So in a in a
sense. My cause at the heart of using mediation program which. If you think about
was not talking mediation I was in many ways.
Acting as an advocate. As much as immediate immediate is supposed to be fair minded and
not take a position.
I think we were mediated to extend that if we couldn't make. Figure out what was the right
answer or before consume is wrong. We only take certain steps but if we felt
the contemporary skating on we recently become advocates. So that point.
Law idea of porn companies working things out and for me and so
on sort of filter back you can force me. That's the way I
see and I'm not sure everybody would agree with it.
The feeling of a vacuum and you force
me. So I think
I give my last three years attorney general's office the new
regional idealist
impulse was pretty much dead.
We have to a government mentor series of three attorneys
general. One of them was a very good experience for me.
They thought they were out of my work.
The last one I can say was as you can read of the song.
John Kerry is not as
nice. And
I didn't like how I ended up in that image. Ministration a day.
I mention that I've been able to run the my mediation program independently at that point.
They were making decisions about the program and I didn't consult me. Which is that Robert F.
But it because it made me feel.
Superannuated. And I didn't want to be one of
those oh get a lawyer that sometimes see an organization just because they've been there for so long.
Nobody can bring stuff to buy them. That certainly don't want to be
disabled. They do it you're trying to
fire. Now I'm the reason why don't you know that about missing.
Spaces name is an art you think it is a great work. And he did great work for most treat.
And there's one area where we had always been deficient in which was
mortgages to people who can really afford them.
That's budgeting mortgages. And he did great work on that.
So. It's not as if I've a grudge his term of office that you
think he used the office in a very constructive way so that point. Consumer protection.
That Wayne was no longer the star
bureau. And. Yes Somebody people
have absorbed the concept of consumer protection that it's less of an even out of
this in the used to be always will be a need but less of
any Ok so. So that.
This is not what I had so I think I was unhappy with the way. My father was being
treated I begin to feel. And he belonged.
I think one positive thing that are you a present you make to give it a positive I was
all
my ideas ever since I got my first time as NY. I wanted to
do creative
writing. And at that point I had enough financial
independence. And that fact they had some success in the stock market and I knew how to go
to market.
That I thought I could leave the
office and be really become potential financial independence.
Which it turned out that that is the case.
So the other factor that I have mentioned about the office was check knowledge.
And this is really really crucial.
So
or. I think I was at all physically disabled people I certainly like
people. Hours of a slow
to project knowledge and to put into
place. But for me to even slow.
So. My lawyer colleagues had e-mail.
Gentlemen how long it was but at least a year before I
did. So I would have to do all my email work from home. I had my own
computer. I trained myself on computers. My boy a computer ninety six.
I had some instruction from a wonderful woman emitting.
So I was able to use it.
And so it took me a long time to get email. Which is a real problem and
I was in the office.
Because crucially communicate.
And like the other communicate your Everybody has a lawyer the bureau's my stuff.
Ultimately I thought things put in place. In terms of email. But I couldn't get access
to all of the systems in the office. I could not get access to the need for a database.
Because of a thing system which is Windows.
Three I think was adequate it. And the speech software put in
a
year and anybody would
use it and let me for a different or this piece of it was
EMS use a later version of Windows I think is ninety five in the
place. And so can access
to the the legal database. I couldn't access. A
complete
database. And I was in love with the
frustrated and I made an issue of this. More more I made an issue. I had huge
fights with our technology people which really kind of
looking. And that's really why tele for
to me. You know. I don't mention every had fifteen thousand prison my office we have fifty
thousand statewide. We had to be
computerized. How technology
people just did not get around to our
system. Of one point some electronic. You know were doing so much work in trying
to get your ex accessible. So much could get paid for it on top of me
as a disabled lawyer who was very very frustrating.
And I remember when I
was. Deciding to resign and I just I was actually quite angry and
it's not good to be that I'm very I'm not talking to a guy respected a lot he was a
senior lawyer in the office on the twenty fifth floor. Which is
executive
offices. I really have a problem and I can gain proper have said
that not. I learned another computer. And I'm you know I'm growing up
and I. I didn't have the wherewithal really I don't have the presence of mind to take him
well actually I need a commitment to be the woman you do. I do my running of like
to be like you have my email you know this is all that I the blind person needs a computer.
Never mind enough of an email.
So that was a big contributor my side leave I was just so angry that I could not gain.
The access that I
wanted it didn't help that they find it hard to know the blind
lawyer. About. I don't know. Months before
I
left. He got his vision I was a new study on its ideas.
He was just prefer job. So when he came aboard she
just conceded everything that I've been fighting for and it undercut my position.
And I can't blame them.
But it's one of those lessons where I
feel. You. If you really really excel the job. It wasn't the
job was one of you not just have it be a job really getting a paycheck. You may just have to fight
like crazy for certain things.
But but in a way it's worked out interesting that
you know you went back to writing. Yes literature which
you refuse. Yes nature. Against.
And it was part of my calculation. If I hadn't helped this interest this desire to
you right.
I probably would not accept the office. But
I know it would have been a real shame because I think the point. Remember I've been in
the puddle. Fourteen years I've done what they could do with it. There are other things that can be treat.
I haven't got the right to visit the offices in Buffalo Syracuse. Rochester. I should have
done
that but I was sir intent on getting all. You know what is it happens
in an office either TONY JONES office or maybe an organization is a Summer time is spent
in meetings and they can cut personal contact with people on the lot of
infrastructure you
need is not put in place public. Certainly true the ages of
as I put infrastructure first meaning.
Manuals. Summaries of laws. I think that
out first. And then everything. Well
and you know.
Mediation cases. Supervising you have to
work. Rejected you obviously by phone.
So that there were certain
things that were nice and there always will be reasons but for the most part. I've been there
for fourteen years I needed something new and I was going to get on the other side. To find
myself into a position. You know what happens in the law is that they say that if
you work in a job for more than three years you pretty much to find the top of that job.
As I said the sign of a consumer protection. But if any mediation.
I think that's true. Yes you do it you can do. Everybody can do
do you. Yes.
So. So you want to do you want to talk a little bit about your writing and writing. And
just one question before you know if you don't really
consider it was ignoring it formally and. I hope
people
send. Relatives. So let's talk
about writing. Well the first began yes.
I have very little published I've had a few titles. I had somewhat published a
disability
that offended by here is an artist.
Published a couple of my essays in his knowledge
is. What I've
written for novels I've written to
memoirs of it and the valor. Several short
stories have been some
essay. And I found
it very warning and he would I find if they want to love
the writing I love. What was at work something out of. Into shape. I'm
a pleasers ever produced to do something like
that but I don't want to be just stuck to that thing I really do want to be out in the world.
What kind of. Characters are really
understood. Was a common characteristic resist.
I you know there are lots of men was written by black people.
And when I said lots I was saying at least a dozen I'm aware of.
Some of the really quite
the. And there have been blind writers in history.
I mean. James Joyce. Have a
provision. James Thurber the cartoonist lost his vision this time
by and thought.
Jorge Luis Borges. You know
Gentile. But no blood drive
to explore with a couple of young adult fiction titles.
No low rider has written fiction with blind characters.
That's pretty remarkable. And anyway. It may be really hasn't been published is written. I've written it.
We haven't even gotten so you know my
first novel is about.
It was based on as a series of incidents in New York City and nine hundred eighty two run the.
Three billion people were killed on the subway.
At the
chime the. He trains and some other Obviously you
have train maybe hey
I had no gates between
cars and so apparently. There are three incidents.
But there were three incidents where it seems that the reason why people are being killed was
that there was this thought they were stepping into the current president that we can't write.
Terrifying to think
about. Now let me just say I don't want people to be able to find by this
because I've always taken precautions against that I would make sure that my
cane tracks. The floor before I step onto
it and I say that. The my misgivings I didn't make it
sound as though these people to know what they were doing. I don't know what exactly happened. But I was
generally thinking to be in the cold. So why the
novel. It's based on that is what it starts on
the systems and has a fourth incident
where a woman is killed by going to mean something. But in this
case like Jessica my fictional
case. She was pushed by
somebody and. The.
The authorities assume that she had
this past and present not
packing. But my main character was a high school
teacher has a lot of misgivings about them one way or the strong more more to
the case.
And he realizes that it's highly unlikely. This woman
truly would have actually made that
mistake and.
The novel builds up so
there. My hero David himself becomes a target of
this
person. Who realizes the day was done to him all these suspects were was
actually
happened and. So in my eyes. I think of it as a suspense novel when you
know right from the beginning right from the very first chapter. Who the perpetrator is.
And he has relations with those characters in the
book. And you realize Momo the some of these characters in real danger.
Know that book that manuscript.
I said to several publishers and agents
inside. HATCH of one publishers one woman in the publishing confidential going to take it.
But then. She was literature another publishing house or did nonfiction. So she
passed along to somebody else and I was into that.
And what I found really frustrating was that agents you read
it after they read it every single thing. They say you know and that's
writing those are the.
But you need to have another stuff. You know you need to have a mystery here.
Well I mean little signal was ready don't have another suspect in it Reza tension is
about whether this person will live to have no do something more dangerous or whether you. Characters are in danger
and rape.
So that's my first novel and.
I have a novel. Based on my most
recent
novel is based on the relationship I had with a woman as a
child I discovered I had this
genetic issue. Nine hundred eighty
three and.
What that did to that
relationship. We had TARP that when you
left your job at the attorney general's office that you wanted to
do some writing. And we spoke a little bit about the writing. But.
Let's talk some more secure the Web site.
Yes my website for all those interested is W W W dot.
Adrian Spratt dot com.
That's a deal has P R A T T V dot
com. You know I
know that's the offices of are saying. Even for several reasons some good some
bad. But it really was the opportunity that
I had wanted to and some point. Become afraid of I think. I'm
never walking down the same old whole way to the same office.
That I've been going to for
the Wallace thirteen years since you know from the World Trade
Center. And I just enjoy that walk in a chair. You know make me feel like
this is my purpose in
life. And then after well you know. In the last two or three years. It felt
different it felt as though.
But I mean for this man I just hate myself if I don't like despatch. Don't really want to
the back of my whole life as
if as if it was walking down a hallway. Today's job that
I know inside out. The answer of course is
no. So I left the
office. And I would say that I was.
I was forty five years
old that the known before retirement age. I had been committed to
my legal career for twenty years.
As well as two years a roast or.
It's giving up a lot.
And it was giving up all the human contact you have given that day. Because any.
The responsibility. Level of status you have with any job
and you know in my case that that I had you had a child was just an attorney general in charge of something or other.
So I had to abandon all that bad and I tried my suits.
And I was a little bit afraid that after to see most of that I get out of my mind.
And from what people tell me that hasn't happened yet.
So I noticed right away into writing even before I left on the idea that I had to hold but
writing the four. I've got several
stories. Then I I
wrote him is producer I've since I started the opposite
in June you know all of us are very biased nearby to know what I wrote while I
was at the
office to bring two men was several short stories. Had a lot of
work. And I thought that investors a months ago. The years ago by.
I took a course with a woman and longer
Siegel's. In two thousand and two. I don't take me about encloses I
feel as though
you. You for the patent committee that's my concern.
But it seems that fee writing courses have taken to convey that yes we can make.
So I think one of the
things I sort of indicated I think and I think the first time you know I talked to
him last.
There's been no published picture in the pipeline writer's midline
capture with Prince.
And not really sure why that would be. I noticed yesterday is
a new title and I did Congress as
the
blurb says. How wonderfully written it is. And so on and so forth. It's
another oblivious fictional period. Despite disabled person.
And it's a young adult you know I don't title.
So I wonder why.
Why fiction. Be published in a young
adult is on that. But not for adults.
When it's convulse like people and blind alters.
I can I find it mysterious and I just
wonder if is it an unwillingness to do with the complexity that adults
might bring to the
subject. It's just one of things I found in the cost
of the book my rival since I left the office.
And not being not having to prove myself in the same means
you do when you left the
office. And that's enough as according the.
How it was a castle.
To figure out how to walk into and
it was in your court room to look to the left turn in my truck and leave
in a dignified fashion. That was all very important.
Then much a part of
appearances of a sighted person doesn't have to go through the effort that
I did to idea in order to achieve that effect.
But a sort of person who is trying to do the same thing
out of touch with the going after that to making sure they don't trip.
Making sure they were wearing the right expression not just serious.
Not too many not him years running a courtroom.
I remember
I was under a lecture at it the
famous universe. Let's put that
way and a very accomplished. Blind Woman.
An
academic was giving a talk.
And here's another receptive audience this is about
disability. And I'm asking a lot of people all the public all the people your history that
disabled or. When valving working with disabled people. Family members
whatever. She was sitting in the audience when she was in to
just after she was introduced you got up and walked to the front.
She obviously had mapped out there when they found.
She started going to the. What I seen was a lecture. Because I had. I wasn't speaking
that I can take what I knew was where I was sitting. Basically and started going when I see
it was a lecture and.
She somehow wandered off into the corner of the room and started addressing the
corner with her back to us and. It was excruciating. That.
I had imagined nobody said anything I think. Well enough to say anything afterwards I may have to
congratulate all the talk. Eventually she somehow figured it out. She somehow managed to find
the right
place and address your distracted events which is great and I trust what you can
never form. And it's just me who remembers
that initial moment. Of discomfort because I've worked so hard
not to have those moments if I can avoid them and show it
happens. So these are things.
When I was at the office. I couldn't really talk about I had checked.
I felt I had
to create this impression that I could function like anybody
else. In much the same way. And obviously that's
not realistic. But I think we'll. You know people can be
very cruel. And there's no doubt about that.
But people are surveying kind and forgiving. And I think even though the numbers
of conscious level.
With. Which are making something differently.
We might make a note of it that moment.
But then that moment
passes. And what we're number is a part
that is positive and it touched my spirits. It is with
disabled people. They say my
case. I can give another look at the station of that it's become very clear to me that been working
with technology. It's going to take a sip of water
here.
I've been going
over all my own papers were having I go up and I
think tonnage.
And I think I don't know the first
recording. You know if there were no computers. As a type everything.
I get everything from
recording. I build my own notes I have very little material in Braille except for
poetry and one of the things that
I I'm reminded by going to buy. I mean my the not by going through
these notes.
Is that I don't think it know how to spell the names of authors.
Characters. For example in the Odyssey. Which I really look at. I was looking at this morning.
All these names. Some of which I
could spell. Like to dismiss a sort of
news but some here the names. I didn't know how to spell interested in how
to spell them. I didn't necessarily hear them right. And so is very reluctant to
say the name. Because it has shown making it.
And I think I know. Now in retrospect. I'm trying to
mimic
sample. I know for instance of the time I
would confuse the gears and Victor is employed in a
word. And I'm pretty sure that I made
mistakes not in those lines. As I taught all the
time when I was using people's
names and. I don't remember people pointing that out to me at all or maybe people didn't.
We're ensuring that was true for a lot of people. Other people may just say you know yours was talking
about why make an issue out of this.
Now that I've got a
computer with my speech. Sense of
justice. It's very easy for me to spell and it
was so this morning is NOT GOING TO MY know it's real all these question marks I wrote to
myself about the spending and you know. Change the subject. Make sure I find it's up if I want the papers
I can spell it right in the paper. Now I just
I. I got a good go. I put in the names
maybe give us some
context. Like a put obviously
Homer and then the name of the
character. And then Google. Go automatically produced.
The rest
ballot and then I can check the spelling. And then you. You know. Go Vols Well
I remember the
spelling. This all the different worlds and aspect like a child life.
Hiding the fact that I couldn't get names right.
So those are things I I thought I hadn't written
about that particular issue I had written about. So choreography of places I call it I think about that.
And another thing I've written about is is this is purely imaginary. And
I in my first novel in the very first chapter.
It's written from the point of view of a woman who's reading her supper a
train and. It occurred to me as I was writing that section.
She's a she's a professional. She's going to an office.
She would probably wear makeup.
Now this is a woman who's never seeing.
Which brings a whole other issue. As a size. I guess and as a digression.
Anybody in the field
nurses but anybody who hears not familiar with dry people probably hasn't given us any thought.
But big big difference between people who've never seen. And people who have
seen is that. When you've never
seen. You've never had.
If the faces in which you can mirror back. Expression.
You know when I started time I was thirteen. By the time I'm sure to even younger.
I had those expressions are part of me.
But people have never
seen. They don't have those expressions or they have to be trained in some
sense. They are still trying to
have expressed as going to say they also have no sense of color. I don't know that that's
true but I do you know that we have
seen whether we still see or don't see those of us who have seen at some point.
Don't know what it's
like when a person is never seeing things in terms of color.
What of a
matching and for them.
What did you think I'm imagining when I'm remembering kind
of. That's Mr Had don't think is
solvable. So the way that comes out in this
first chapter of this novel. Is this woman's wearing makeup.
So I'm thinking to myself as as as I'm writing this section. So what did you think about makeup
what what what does it mean to her.
And so I'd never talk I don't. I may have been I don't think I've talked to a blind woman a congenitally
blind woman about this. But I
imagined that it must feel like a somewhat artificial exercise that she's doing
this because she knows. It makes the right impression.
Even though she's not. She doesn't know the say firsthand what that impression it.
She knows is
good but why. Chemistry. I just assume that's a mystery.
And yet you have to get it right.
So she's going to be a bit self-conscious about it she kind of want one of the women friends.
To confirm for her some way. This is got it right so I imagine her projecting for.
But you have arrived at the office and. One of her women friends taking the siding just just
sticking it up a little bit.
So these are things. I'm able to get my writing.
These are the things that I think by people in the professional setting in the. How do
a world of the outside world
rather can't really talk about the things that have to be worked out.
He's on our
own over the help of people who have some insight into all of this.
When you are writing like that for if you know. Yes if the. Did you write it on a computer.
Yes there was a speech. If I had it you
know that's really interesting.
I had read a lot of stories and poems name poems and
sure because I could work. Community in Braille
because I think a lot before I got this piece of the size
computer problem what that I couldn't really edit and and the reason was I
was working. So many hours a day with readers
probably most a twelve hours a
day and and that's to do my little work
occult and Hoddy I
just I just I didn't want to pay for other Another reader and that's
probably true. I wasn't earning a lot of
money but beyond that I just wanted to be by myself some of the to say.
So you know to work with somebody else. Revising one of my stories which would mean you know going to
and having this person make handwritten corrections. And if need be we type thing out the whole thing.
And it just meant more time that I couldn't HAVE to myself and I really created.
I seem to be one of those people who needs to have time to myself a lot of it.
So do you answer your question.
My first computer went hand in hand with my writing my first novel and I was not a
coincidence. I got the computer in the end of nine hundred eighty six.
I guess I mention this before. That's. I
did a little training with a woman a man
day. One thirty five West. Twenty third Street which is
where this is a building the number of people live. And she she has this
training. I guess business.
Here's a very helpful.
So what does a what you work in this business and as with a speech and computer.
I could hear what I was actually typing. I could go back I could edit I could
move sentences from one place to another place. Check my
spelling all the things I know we have to do before. Except for the reader. And if I could do my own.
For the difference in the world. And how it's
being changed now with
prepared. Well. We're writing or
just in general yeah.
OK. So since I left the
office. There had been that being warned. Advance. After the
next was quite really amazing terms of my
independence. When I left the office. I hired someone to come
into afternoons a week I figured I'd need to have all my mail
read. I need a paper.
With Somebody. A lot of my correspondents
from from friends would still have to be read.
Now. Almost all my correspondence is by e-mail I don't get any of that
anymore nobody does.
And of second to my own emails
reply. I can I.
I think I mentioned that I need to invest in order to keep a float.
Can do all that by myself. The Their web site
is completely accessible to the extent that I need accessibility. I say that because
I don't do it options and that's a whole other issue. But even that even there are pretty there
are accessible. Pretty amazing to me.
And I know what I want to broker and cite troublous the broker. Yes yes yes.
And I don't know what other Web sites are also accessible I mean in their figure
logy of
the other investment work Web sites.
So yeah it was in my book and I can do everything myself which is very liberating.
And so the only
thing. The main use I have to read and now. I only have a person come in once
a week one afternoon. Is.
I just have this person read back. What I'm either
written or heavily edited in the preceding
week. Because. I
find. That when I listen to things on the computer think that I've
written. They can sound pretty good. But when everybody
human was some somebody out of Christianity. Comes out. It's very hard
to
explain this I have a ping people understand it into to play but the
least I need to hear their material rep
and every time you step back. I spend the next day to making terms of evasions.
So you know the computer doesn't answer all the questions for me. But certainly this is most of them and it
means. Whereas when I left office I thought was going to be very dependent
on on my partner and I don't read it I would
have to
hire. That has not been the case at all pay all my bills
online. With one to perceptions.
Notably hospital business. The
hospital websites of a difficult
time in terms of accessibility.
It's interesting thing with the.
Because I have so many stories about hospitals and it's just not worth getting that.
They're just very very frustrating.
The frustrating for everybody. Doubly frustrating when you have to deal with accessibility
issues. The softer expense to get on your
computer with the three of
you suck by using the plan is the most widely used in that world order.
Well and say going up into sub process somewhere. Sockeye is called
Jobs which was originally an acronym for job. Access with speech.
Is made by company that closes our freedom time to pick. I believe I have
brought in a long time to develop or so many years. I've been using this one
for more than twenty years now.
I believe it now costs. Approaching nine hundred dollars for the
original contract. Legace really expensive is that you have to buy.
And the maintenance contract. Every two years.
I miss paying I think two hundred dollars by annually for that.
I think it's every Just a price for the next one. To something over one
hundred. Which is a big help.
The euro so it's not just the software you have to make sure that when you get
a computer it has sufficient run. Because George isn't up a lot.
I have to have to speak. Well. I choose to have a speech at the time
this is very good. So there are other expenses.
But they come down a lot of people who use the i Phone to.
I think a lesser extent. Enjoyed for those.
Probably
have less expense and. They seem very very happy with it I
am not convinced and I'm really very deft i Phone your to some not really someone you can talk about it
with. I find it.
Some of the operations that I do in a second. Require several steps named I just want to deal with that.
I think those are there and I know that you know providing novels or even stories like pieces.
But I think you know this is this is obviously a problem you know. So many black people
don't have resources.
I and force and enough that I do. Expense is a real
issue. And people really have to struggle with that little you know I want to list of people
here stores and
we share. Tips. You know if I have a question I posed a
question and usually get a good answer some because of the question I'm
like that.
I find the question of how do we have for the next maintenance contract how do
I buy this or that it really is those are real issues for black people.
So we disagree about everything and just this morning there's a third
about whether it's better to read a book.
Just because it by a human
voice or whether to use
some. Speech synthesis application. And so people actually
believe is better with the speech that this is because they can speed up the recording to me have
them be able
to I've that's working me for of it was in newspapers like The New York
Times which is really use it for it works for
a nonfiction work but the fiction works where characters are speaking they aren't
always. Introduced to the reader you're just you know from context. I would find
that really difficult and I do find it depressed tried it.
You mentioned the threat is there like.
Groups If you want
to discuss these issues.
Well I can it is this is this is it is never one clear. Yeah.
So that's it said would be a a discussion to have on that
list. Is after and which way is it a specific a specific you.
People his job. This is how we see. OK.
It be like. You know there might be a list for People Who Cook.
And like the list for people who fly planes into their all these lessons you know.
This is because of this one is percent of the jaws
users. How can you talk a little bit more
or about. You know this technology helped you write and
help you communicate through technology has helped you write. Yes and helped
you view your finances.
How do you do manage to do technology whether aspects of your life
or what
have you
know reading a position to talk about this. Only because I
don't use it. I've tried a lot of people now use technology
for G.P.S.
technology.
When I tried it.
Well I think I've suffered
this back I just spent most of my
life. Making sure that I knew where I was
so that we not only worse go to you. But how I was going to get there. So I would ask
people when I get you office. What throw you on who read your door in
the hallway. Left right or that sort of thing.
Obviously G.P.S. is going to help
that. But it can help people who are
unfamiliar unfamiliar returns to get from other know from a store to a hotel.
Hotel to a restaurant or living like the I understand People use of not the best.
When I might tend to do. The tense use that
technology. I found
that he created by voting. There is maybe thirty feet away. Such
if it were next door to me. Think that that. And
I think I mean I think that has a lot to do with living in
New York City. The G.P.S. does not work as well and I remember there's a recording
by one of the. Disability centers where
they are going to demonstrate G.P.S. and it has to people go out on the street
is it. You know I'm standing at the corner of such and such and I'm going to go up to such and such and.
This is going to tell me when I reach the corner and then it's going to tell me as I'm walking along this street that street.
Well I don't really work hard in using Jimmy was
really musing in a sense are you really wanted to work. And it's a shame when it doesn't. I think eyes to see Mr
President
many top buildings. There's so much radiation of one kind or another in
this city. But I
think it's probably also designed for people in cars.
Well you know the people you know I don't use it. I have actually listened to
the demonstrations from other places where they might be more room for
all it's a smaller
town and he does seem to help people. I could see that it be it would
be
useful. But a portion of the person to talk about because I haven't had a good
experience with it. And I haven't really needed it.
But you do actually I know that you. Good around.
Yes. How is that change.
Because knowledge. One great change in New York City that has this
is specifically New York City. Is it a noun. How long is
the next train to take to get to the station. And that's really nice to know. They
have sirens and sometimes are
those verbal enough Mr forthcoming.
So people vision can see the signs but it is really nice to know
that the next train to such and such is going to arrive in four minutes. That's nice.
Otherwise known as this is my old fashioned way of actually one of my friends were suggesting that I take your reporting
of how I handle the subway. And I don't want to make it sound as though I'm the only one who does the subway.
Many people do. And they don't have a different techniques. But I think
if it is a strategic of something.
Granted you know I'm at a truck Street Station in the what we call the two three line. This is
an express train I'm in the last stop in Brooklyn before. When Hans Wall
Street and. And then been in
Russia. I mean I still do this today but in Russia particularly which I
have voiced now.
I would go through the turnstiles I take the elevator down to a color the A
listers at the steps and steps needed to the platform. So I go through that whole bridge that's
pretty straightforward. And so I let my computer just
spoke to
us so
I made on the platform near the bottom as that's not at the bottom the steps I think I want to get in people's way.
For the train to come in.
And you know coming pretty fast. Whenever Snowden so does.
And then has a certain point. I could always
estimate. Whatever still moving. I could by came forward
to just a side of the
car. And then it just belts a little bit.
So that when it came to stop. I know exactly where the doors were.
It was very important me to position myself right with it was going to open so that I'd
follow the car to the left make
a pencil and just for the doors to
open. And then going to the door get open. I put my cane.
On to the floor of the subway. For two reasons one to make sure that it was the floor. For the step
onto a number two.
To make sure I was going to you know walk into somebody or step in somebody speed.
And I obviously wasn't happy open gates was a lot of people I was getting on the train. And they would
automatically just give me enough space to get on.
And then I would never step onto the train and then find something
to and. And you can imagine that there were a.
People who are really scared for me. When they saw me touching this train as it was
moving or step. You know it's I think pretty near the platform as now I would not stand in the platform edge.
Before the train came in
because you know when I'm traveling in France for
example if your mother. If you're on a suburban
train platform. Near
Paris. You will also of the A line.
Rather Tasia very the.
The the pathos trains.
If you're on the edge of that platform. In fact if you're even within a yard of that
of even farther away than those trains command. They have to blow you right off the tracks.
Right off the platform under the child's father. That might happen in the subway not.
Not problems likely but still it is dangerous.
So I've noticed started at least a yard away from us that yellow. Rough line.
As my guide. And then when the train was as I said when it's done I would
move forward in touch it but you know people not knowing what my strategy was with find that very nerve
wracking. And trademark expensive people and. What would be a real
problem. You know take some concentration to do that if somebody would see me
and they get very nervous. And then
they grab my arm and. You know what I do you do
I say thank you very much. Fine or. But or do I check three
because they're staying up my trying. My concentration.
Hermosa time. I
think you know most of
us. Well. And you know raising a hot issue the issue
of the systems and how do you handle
assistance. I think for another disabled people. It's a
very troubling
issue. It's taking a sip of water
here. I mean them
for maybe twenty years ago.
There's a pop up a piece in The Times. And I think I can say the guy's name because he published
a guy named Jason Ivan saw really good
guy who worked for the American politician for the blind when it was here in New York is now with care. Dollars.
And I'm not sure what his status is now.
He was responsible as far as I know. Starting a publication called
Access Well Rich is one of the. I will say is it the
preeminent online publication
for accessibility information whether it's
for. Computers for. I
Phone for watches and dryers G.P.S. devices all sorts of things.
He saw that I think. I know he would have attacked. In any way he said he wrote
this op ed piece.
In which you described walking to some intersection.
And somebody grabbing his armies just he's he's writing about how he just rigid people
are not keep insisting on giving this a sense that they realize that they that he
can do this by himself and perforating I mean to be doing quite justice but that's roughly the turn of
the piece. So it happened there few weeks later
I was at a loyalist convention thinking.
Dinner. And another band that I knew in New York.
Michael. I knew him from North girl.
We were talking about this op ed piece and matter said.
You know. Jerry. I think about Jerry's resists. So it's just really we're talking to Jay I said.
And like I said Jerry you know. That's all I meet women.
And so you know for me. There are times I was assistants and
really clever people offer it that tries and I don't want to
systems. And it's really nice him people of fridge. And I say.
Slightly friendly and find dance and then
they leave me alone.
It's a real problem in people are
persistent and they want to give you a loan.
You know. Can you continue to be polite is a point where you just have to
be kind of mood and direct and say look I'm sorry I'm find go with it.
It may not be an obvious example but one that comes to mind is
a stretcher. As a block a few blocks away from
where we are
now under a mystery.
Where the Sidewalk is kind of uneven the paving
stones
are up and down up and down and say just a trickle in it. And the the
building learned to call it. Read the the was come in I want to meet
the sidewalk. The building one isn't even some shut out some
doing stuff going down steps setting
up so it's a block that takes for me. Some concentration.
You know when you're walking along a block if you've got a building line is straight is great because you can pretty much
follow it and keep a straight line.
If you don't have a straight Building nine. Your best guide and
us even if you have a straight one. Your best guide is
traffic. And that's a little bit tricky
because it's not as if you hear traffic in a straight line when you're walking toward it.
Chuck with him to come from Yemen but it is likely used to describe business for the help
and traffic would seem to come from an outdoor somewhat ahead of you.
And then go behind you someone has a different angle. And you just suck accustom yourself to how the
angle
fields. To to
to. Or yourself to this notion of a straight line. You know.
Often have will happen to me for a while
but he used to happen all the time. People receive me as a passing by.
Just walk straight what straight was straight.
And I want to say they were in the nation to walk.
Because when you can
see you thinking. Looking at
some object. Ahead. It might be a building at the end of the street might
be. A signpost. But consciously.
You're keeping a straight line on the sidewalk. In relation to other things around us if
you Clancy. You don't have those
objects to walk in relationship.
So you have to find some method to compensate. So in my case I'm talking about traffic. Building.
Sometimes it might be a crack in the sidewalk and any number of things in it or to go back and saying I
was always brought on history.
I was not a getting this block.
I tried to go to a good speed because I find if I go to slowly I sorta lose my rhythm.
Try to keep the rhythm going to die.
Helps in a lot of
ways was a woman walking on the other side of the street obviously following me
very closely respect for make me nervous I hate being watched closely. But
it's like when people walk behind me in a day. That clearly just just starting what I'm doing.
Make me they never. But she's just got is really the voice. This is
burying your
Because on the left. Dissipating a third coming up we're going
to trip. Is this went on and on and I know I know it's fine really honestly.
Really fine. So slow so fine that it will you please be quiet. I turn.
And
I think she was offended. So learn I have this expression.
Nasty Blind test. Which you mean kind of I want to get there are nasty black
people is one of those neighborhoods medium pleasant to people when they try to help.
But for the most part. It just is the dilemma that I think a lot of people
have how do you respond to help. And in what circumstances.
So have you have you written. If you have your fiction or nonfiction about.
If you could read some of the situation as I have. Yeah.
OK. Yes. It is this isn't the first time.
Why. I wish I could get this purpose because
this. Is this.
In this is there's a way in which blind people live in a different
world and a way which we live in the same
world. And I think the main reasons reliving a different world to extend the
reader is because there's
just so little understanding
of what the differences are. And why the IP People see why there
are differences.
The difference is now. Needless to say.
You know if people understood that when a child me to walk in a straight line is just walk straight ahead.
It doesn't mean anything in itself. It's what say.
Understand why it doesn't make sense to me. The BE FINE.
But
sometimes when I think I'm just being obstinate. I can. I can come across as rude.
I don't The happens a lot when I know that people do community Pangea if you're under a lot of pressure in
any moment. If you've a
tired you absent always variable.
You know one of my. We had friends over that's
like. And
I did by going to this guy's not detect.
That's not a coincidence or Christmas is that
he has been involved in Advocate you work at one
time or another for disabled
people and.
One of the things that became clear that discussing it stated. This is an
office in in New York City. I don't really want to can to specifics here but I want to get concepts across.
Let's not assume New York
City. To promote the interests of the disabled people
of disabled people.
And their function is primarily to remove
obstacles. I can give you an illustration of why home life.
Like the GET BY know about the point things out to you and of course that will help the people on the table
Mrs funny that I'm having this
issue. In my apartment I have. I have to get an apartment I have
one
bathroom. My brother renovated if you for I moved in with a really
great does Venice
shop one of the ideas was the was. When I bought
this apartment. A big space in the foyer really front
doors. Right now that space is filled with a rather
nice cabinet of of cupboards and drawers. Which my brother built. You know.
Afterward. His the original idea there was to put a show stone in there.
So I would have what really stick people call it but not enough. Which
would be useful for me because I have two bedrooms means you know two people in
the bathroom and same time. It also enhances the value of an apartment in New York City.
I couldn't do it. I couldn't have been installed. And the reason they couldn't wasn't wouldn't be real church sensible.
There's no way could be made in your chest or wheelchair accessible. That space by the five daughters will have
room to maneuver.
In fact this whole apartment doesn't have room for. We'll chat room to maneuver.
But I spoke to the guy who's ahead of that office by chance of a party and
expensive to Asian to him
just not not not to get him to knock in France into after might be hard for then
he wouldn't but just to get his reaction he
said you know I mean it is going to be great for you know you know to be there forever somebody else is going to move in. Well you
know it's not a
practical.
There's something you just modify. Anyway that's a personal view.
But the concept I want to get across is that their focus
is. Removing obstacles.
My friends focus is on creating opportunities for disabled people.
As an architect has a lot of contact with
developers. And people involved in
construction and. He is working with another to shrink
government to try to create opportunities
for disabled people. And it occurred to
me as we were
talking that that really needs to be the focus that if
you create opportunities for disabled people.
The removal of obstacles will follow.
It just
happened. And.
Just to stick that gets bandied around all the time. I don't know this is true that.
Maybe seventy five percent or eighty five eighty percent
of all people or blind people in employment age. I'm employed.
Which is obviously an extraordinarily high rate.
So I think. My sense is that there
is not just this.
This movement was creating opportunities that that should
be overseen education
areas. I mention how things are changing
colleges and universities and even my dad being with us that last quarter was as it was six people.
But by
people. So that that's
my point even though I've sort of come to an end with saying it in a funny way.
OK Is there anything else you want to
talk about. Well you know look I want to
see if you hadn't but what do you know if we don't have isn't your neck and then but now.
You know. Well. Because it's a good good question. Well it's a question that
I
was always about about because
I in fact. You
know there's a culture in. Have rejected in
Canada has left the guy. He was a quadriplegic.
And he can change I think for an hour can pave I think they were syndicated nationwide.
The with the ones that I
remember was back in the hit. It's a
it's a
drawing of a blind
guy holding out a car. Obviously
packing. And the caption is. Please help.
I'm black and blind but not musical.
And he was you know. It is so it was so true.
And I was so focused on academic work. And then you
know legal work inside. You know my hope is where essentially listening to music which is kind
of a passive activity. One of the nice thing since I bought this
apartment which is that. For those who don't know me. Is a terrace apartment.
Meaning I have terrace. I can now. Yes but you're into square
feet. Now have a lot of cancer out there so long I've become
gardeners and. It's a whole new thing for me. And to you know what's the
current grow. You know the sort of miracle of tomatoes appearing.
Flowers or pay. Hearing. Lavender turning into something really special.
That's just that's becoming a part of my
life. So if your
tomato plants are actually
very complete your tomato plants are actually better than mine. That's for.
Well you know you always are upstate. So I think between being in
a slightly more southerly climb and on the nice floor which is high.
It's a lot of another
so. Currently my notes are just trying
to see it as anything else I want to
mention.
And it's just so ripping us kind of
wondering what I had in mind.
OK Well thank you very much.
Why you made this interview really easy I don't have to suffer the people listening.
But you have a lot to do with how it turned out well. You have a lot to do with
that hundred THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU. It.